Buongiorno a tutti Io sono la copia
originale di Viviana Varese Chi è
Viviana Varese Viviana Varese è uno chef
una stella Michelin ha un ristorante
stellato a Milano all'interno di
talismeraldo e due ristoranti al momento
in Sicilia uno all'interno di un
boutique hotel Nella campagna di Noto
dove ha ritrovato il contatto con la
natura e con gli elementi naturali la
terra l'acqua l'aria il fuoco e un
Bistrot invece in centro a Noto
all'interno di un palazzo barocco Io
sono Irene Voltolini sono una sua copia
originale un tempo mi definiva la
responsabile Sony del ristorante ora
sono semplicemente il suo direttore
operativo
Viviana Varese è un manifesto che
racconta quello che lei è quello che lei
Cerca di trasmettere agli altri
attraverso la sua cucina perché
ovviamente gli ideali che uno ha si
trasmettono in qualsiasi cosa uno fa
il suo manifesto all'interno del nostro
ristorante parla di entusiasmo di gioia
di sostenibilità di biodiversità di
inclusione di amore per il cibo e non
solo
in cucina non esiste l'originale
Esistono le copie originali una ricetta
un'idea gastronomica un piatto sono il
risultato dell'esperienza delle
tradizioni dei sapori che ci sono stati
tramandati del dizionario del gusto che
sviluppiamo assaggiando Ogni volta
sempre Non solo da cuochi o da chef Ma
da quando siamo nati dalla
contaminazione di tutti i linguaggi
culinari e degli ingredienti
Innanzitutto dall'inizio Copiamo dalla
mamma così ha iniziato a fare Viviana
Varese e ce lo racconta lei stessa in
questo breve video
[Musica]
e questa è la sua mamma ovviamente
mia madre è stata la mia fonte
d'ispirazione
lei mi ha insegnato Il rispetto del
Lavoro la costanza
da lei ho preso i gesti fare un semplice
pomodoro pulire il pesce
gessi rudimentali di una cucina di
famiglia una cucina rassicurante e del
focolare Grazie a lei ho costruito una
biblioteca dei sapori una memoria del
Gusto sono partiti da una cucina
tradizionale per poi rivisitarle
stravolgendo l'aspetto le consistenze e
la forma
[Musica]
cos'è il processo creativo il processo
creativo è la capacità di creare
qualcosa di nuovo ispirandosi al passato
Copiamo dalla mamma quindi occupiamo dai
maestri per poi omaggiarli con piatti a
loro ispirati Copiamo dei libri degli
chef Copiamo dai nostri capo partita
quando siamo come di cucina Copiamo
dalle arti dalla natura Copiamo
fondamentalmente dalla vita
imitare nel creare fa parte
dell'imparare e il palato si Affina con
la sperimentazione L'esperienza e il
viaggio non c'è nulla di veramente
autentico
autentici però devono essere sempre il
rispetto della materia prima la scelta
di essere etici e sostenibili con le
stagioni con i produttori con i cuochi
della nostra Brigata
autentico deve essere sempre l'approccio
al cucinare come atto politico perché
come lo facciamo determina che cosa
vogliamo trasmettere agli altri chi
siamo e che cosa vogliamo comunicare non
solo nel nostro ristorante Ma nella
società in cui viviamo
Mamma Carla la mamma la madre di Viviana
Varese fa da sempre la pasta e patate e
il suo piatto storico Loro sono
originari della Costiera Amalfitana
ma non fatta a julienne perché come
spesso lei racconta le fa la maniera sua
non ha la tecnica una tecnica da mamma
però dovunque vada e per chiunque cucine
il suo gesto d'amore e il suo modo per
mostrare chi è e preparare la pasta e
patate alla sua maniera vi viene a
Varese ad ogni cambio di menù e ve lo
posso raccontare perché la conosco da 10
anni e quindi assaggia i suoi piatti e
racconti i suoi piatti da 10 anni ne
crea una
è la rivisitazione dell'originale di
mamma Carla ma si evolve e la
reinterpreta perché la cucina è un
movimento che riproduce attingendo
soprattutto dalla propria storia dalla
storia del cibo ma anche dalla storia
degli uomini che lo fanno
Qui abbiamo due paste patate di Viviana
Varese della storia di Viviana Varese
una è una pasta e patate di mare con
estratto di basilico totanetti e
pecorino poi abbiamo un'altra pasta che
si evolve anche nel modo di raccontare
dolce come un bacio salato sono delle
conchiglie di pasta con una crema di
patate pecorino degli Anemoni di mare
fritti e dei pinoli
creare un piatto e mettersi in gioco
esprimere Sempre se stessi e raccontare
il proprio vissuto la pasta e patate che
abbiamo in carta Oggi è il Barocco nasce
in Sicilia dove Viviana Varese è
arrivata negli ultimi due anni quindi è
una pasta siciliana che sono degli
anellini siciliani pasta fresca prodotta
all'interno di questo Bistrot con patate
affumicata perché c'è stata
un'evoluzione quindi la riscoperta del
fuoco e della Cenere come metodo di
cottura e un pezzo di pistacchio deviana
Varese negli ultimi anni attraverso la
tecnologia alimentare ha creato anche
una serie di prodotti che sono Conserve
marmellate e pesti e quindi in questo
sia l'evoluzione è sempre la pasta e
patate una coppia di quella di mamma ma
diversa
cucinare un atto sacro una magia che ti
fa tornare bambino Queste sono le parole
che dice sempre Viviana Varese
e lei nasce al fuoco i suoi genitori
avevano un ristorante nasce all'interno
di un ristorante una chef autodidatta e
nasce pizzaiola 13 anni faceva già le
pizze ed è dall'infanzia che utilizza il
copiare con un esercizio per imparare e
sperimentare e spesso al fuoco ritorna
ritorna perché un elemento che le dà
gioia entusiasmo la fai lo stesso tempo
tornare bambina e sviluppare la propria
creatività
e da sempre c'è la pizza nei suoi eventi
nei suoi ristoranti una pizza che però
negli anni ha viaggiato E viaggiando si
è voluta è cambiata si è modificata Si è
anche autocopiata in un certo senso
pizza fritta pizza al vapore una pizza
con bavarese al pomodoro gli ingredienti
base quelli della sua storia della sua
tradizione della sua infanzia della sua
biblioteca dei sapori sono sempre il
pomodoro la mozzarella il basilico il
grano ma ora utilizza grani autoctoni
sceglie il produttore dei propri
prodotti e poi sperimenta
Copiamo anche dai maestri dai grandi
maestri
Pablo Picasso diceva se siete dei bravi
artisti si copia se siete grandi artisti
si ruba e così Ogni tanto fa anche
lasciarvi via Novarese conosce anche
Leon spagnolo che porta nella cucina
l'utilizzo del plancton e così ruba
questo ingrediente dalla storia della
cucina e realizza questo risotto al
plancton con brodo di seppia ajoli e
lime e siccome un piatto va anche
raccontato e la storia di un piatto la
copia
dell'originale va anche raccontata e per
essere etici va anche diciamo tradotte e
dichiarata
lo dichiarava anche in questo piatto che
viene proposto con questa fotografia
almeno il microscopio di tutti gli
esseri viventi che
costituiscono il plancton
e poi un grande maestro di Viviana
Varese era Gualtiero Marchesi e questo è
uno dei piatti diciamo storici della
chef Un raviolo aperto di seppia ripieno
di capesante gamberi e frutti di mare
scottati con salsa d'arancia l'agrume è
l'originalità di Viviana barese nel
senso che è uno dei suoi ingredienti
principe quello che la segue nel suo
percorso formativo e di chef
l'innovazione ci apre sempre nuove
possibilità a strumenti metodi
conservazione di cottura diversi ma è la
memoria delle emozioni che un piatto ci
ha dato a generare consistente
combinazioni giochi di luce e colori
accostamenti e rielaborazioni
lo spaghetto alle vongole come lo fa
mamma tu non lo sai fa spaghetti alle
vongole uno dei piatti classici la
cucina mediterranea della cucina campana
Viviana Varese la rielaborato e oggi e
da molti anni è l'insuperabile un super
spaghettino con brodo intenso di
Anguilla affumicata vongole e polveri
tarallo e limone
lo riproducono i cuochi della Brigata da
più di 10 anni il loro compito di farlo
autentico sempre come lo farebbe lei
una quasi perfetta copia dell'originale
Perché da noi si dice in cucina in sala
nei ristoranti di via Novarese la
perfezione non esiste Ma questa è
un'altra storia perché anche il nome di
un altro storico piatto di Viviana
Varese che vi invito a venire ad
assaggiare
Che cos'è la creatività anche in cucina
siamo in una università noi pensiamo che
la creatività sia una facoltà
accessibile a tutti
e accessibile a tutti se sappiamo
studiare il passato quello da dove
arriviamo viverci il presente con tutte
le sue differenze azioni e tutte le sue
unicità e in qualche modo avere e
cercare di avere sempre in cucina in
quello che mangiamo in quello che
facciamo una visione il più possibile
etica e innovativa del futuro grazie
[Applauso]